oui je suis timide la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribué il n'y
a pas
d'observation le procèsverbal est adopté
sous les réserves
d'usage
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
presque 3 ans jour pour jour après
l'assassinat de Samuel paatti dont nous
commémorons aujourd'hui le triste
anniversaire la République a de nouveau
été prise pour cible une fois de plus
une fois de trop à haras le terrorisme
islamiste s'en est pris à plusieurs
enseignants et personnels éducatifs
Dominique que Bernard dont le seul crime
était d'être professeur de lettre a été
lâchement assassiné une fois de plus une
fois de trop ce sont nos valeurs qui
sont attaquées notre vivre ensemble qui
est menacé notre capacité à rester unis
qui est
testé je tiens au nom du Sénat et
particulièrement de nos collègues
sénatrices et sénateurs du Pas de Calais
à exprimé notre compassion et notre
soutien à la famille de Dominique
Bernard à ses proches et aux autres
victimes qui restent actuellement
hospitalisées ainsi qu'à la communauté
éducative et aux élèves du lycée
Gambetta
d'aras monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vous invite à observer un
moment de recueillement en la mémoire de
Dominique
Bernard
j'ai le regret de vous faire part du
décès de nos anciens collègues Yannick
Baudin qui fut sénateur de la scèmard de
2004 à
2011 René garek qui fut sénateur du
Calvados de 1998 à 2014 il présida la
commission des lois de notre assemblée
avant d'en devenir le
queur l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion à nouvelle lecture du projet
de loi considéré comme adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale en application de
l'article 49 Alina 3 de la Constitution
de programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à
2027 dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Thomas CASNAV
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics monsieur le Président Monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les les
sénateurs avant de débuter je voudrais
naturellement m'associer à
l'hommage que nous avons rendu à
Dominique Bernard ainsi qu'à Samuel pti
lâchement assassiné parce qu'il
défendait les valeurs de la
République je suis néanmoins très
heureux d'être devant vous ce soir pour
l'examen en nouvelle lecture du projet
de loi de programme
des finances publiques le projet de LPFP
que porte le gouvernement est bien plus
qu'un texte de méthode pour la gestion
de nos finances publiques le
gouvernement a fait des choix clairs
pour vous proposer une trajectoire qui
concilie le rétablissement de nos
comptes publics tout en investissement
en investissant dans l'avenir à la fois
pour nos services publicique et pour la
transition écologique la série
d'amendements que le gouvernement vous
propose vise à mettre le texte en
cohérence avec la vision que nous avons
aujourd'hui de notre trajectoire
économique et financière nous souhaitons
ainsi rétablir le texte dans sa version
telle qu'adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale et sur le laquelle le
gouvernement a engager sa responsabilité
le 27 septembre
dernier par rapport au texte qui a été
discuté l'an passé nous nous fixons un
objectif de déficit plus ambitieux le
texte initial prévoit une réduction du
déficit public à 2,9 % du PIB en 2027
désormais nous visons un objectif de 2,7
% en cela le Sénat a été écouté j'ai
bien conscience que la majorité
sénatoriale souhaite que nous allions
plus loin s'agissant de la maîtrise des
dépenses de l'État mais la trajectoire
adoptée par la commission des finances
du Sénat en nouvelle lecture ne nous
paraît ni réaliste ni souhaitable je
pense notamment à la réduction d'au
moins 5 % du nombre d'agents publics de
l'État et de ses opérateurs qui n'est
pas compatible avec le réarmement des
services publics de première ligne ni
avec l'investissement que les Français
attendent pour la transition
écologique cette loi de programmation
est un élément central de notre
crédibilité j'observe qu'une question
préalable a été déposée par le groupe
CRCE je formule le souhait qu'elle ne
soit pas adopté dans la mesure où nous
avons besoin de ce cadre dans les années
à venir c'est un enjeu de crédibilité
pour notre pays nous devons d'abord nous
montrer crédiible vis-à-vis des Français
qui ont besoin de connaître le chemin
que nous allons
emprunter celui d'un retour à la normale
après des années de crise et de savoir
comment nous allons financer dans les
années qui viennent les services publics
et l'investissement dans les priorités
d'avenir il s'agit également d'assurer
notre crédibilité vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens à cette fin nous
traduisons les objectifs fixés dans le
programme de stabilité mais aussi il est
essentiel que la France démontre sa
capacité à se donner un cap une
trajectoire et un véritable cadre pour
le redressement de ces finances
publiques pouvons-nous nous permettre de
ne pas avoir de lois de programmation
des finances publiques deux versements
du plan de relance européen sont en jeu
un premier de 10 milliards d'euros qui
doit intervenir cette année et un second
de 8 milliards d'euros l'année prochaine
sans loi de programmation plriannuel ces
fonds ne nous seraient pas versés il
convient enfin d'assoir notre
crédibilité vis-à-vis des investisseurs
qui achète notre dette dans un contexte
de remontée des taux d'intérêt en
quelques mois nos taux d'emprunt sont
passés d'une valeur proche de zéro à des
niveaux supérieurs à 3 % sur nos
obligations à 10 ans
s'agissant de notre crédibilité je ferai
une remarque sur nos hypothèses de
croissance elles sont régulièrement
qualifiées d'optimiste à court terme
nous prévoyons une croissance de 1,4 %
après 1% en 2023 c'est davantage que la
prévision de la Banque de France à 0,9 %
il est vrai mais notre prévision est en
ligne avec celle des grands organismes
internationaux 1,2 % pour la Commission
européenne 1,2 % également pour l'OCDE
1,3 % pour le FMI dans sa dernière
prévision qui date de la semaine
dernière en ce qui concerne la
croissance potentielle notre estimation
à + 1,35 % par an jusqu'en 2027 est
également proche des prévisions établies
par les instituts qui tiennent compte de
nos réforme comme le FMI ou le FCE notre
prévision de croissance potentielle
s'appuie sur le fait que les réformes
que nous conduisons vont se poursuivre
la réforme des retraites celle de
l'assurant chômage la réforme du lycée
professionnel le succès de
l'apprentissage l'application des plans
d'investissement et la baisse des impôts
de production qui se poursuivra en
2024 je souhaite enfin revenir sur le
rythme de rétablissement de nos finances
publiques pour justifier devant vous la
trajectoire que nous avons
fixée la France a besoin de définir un
cap pour ces finances publiques la
trajectoire que nous vous proposons
d'intégrer à ce texte doit nous Perm
permettre de tenir nos compte
aujourd'hui comme demain y parvenir
suppose de partager un même sentiment de
responsabilité mais également de
répartir l'effort entre l'ensemble des
administrations publiques l'État et ses
opérateurs la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités
territoriales nous le savons une
consolidation trop rapide casserait la
croissance et engendrerait plus de
dépenses et moins de recettes qu'elle ne
permettrait d'économie c'est pourquoi
nous assumons une stratégie de réduction
progressive du déficit laquelle permet
de poursuivre l'investissement dans les
services publics dans la transition
écologique et les baisses d'impôts par
rapport au texte qui vous a été présenté
il y a un an nous proposons cependant
une trajectoire de retour sous les TR %
de déficit public légèrement plus rapide
nous visons 2,7 % 2027 au lieu de 2,9 %
initialement pour y parvenir nous
comptons réduire fortement la part des
dépenses publiques dans le PIB même si
elles continueront à croître en euros et
nous stabilisons à 44,4 % la part des
prélèvements
obligatoire cela implique de réaliser
plus de 12 milliards d'euros d'économie
à partir de 2025 réparti à parts égales
entre l'État et ses opérateurs d'une
part et la sécurité sociale d'autre part
nous assumons le fait que ces économies
doivent être documentées et nous
souhaitons associer les parlementaires
pour identifier les dispositifs de
politique publique qui au vu des travaux
parlementaires permettrai de faire
l'objet d'une mission de revue de
dépenses le thème des économies a été
abordé par plusieurs groupes
parlementaires au cours des réunions des
dialogues de Bery nous souhaitons
poursuivre ces échanges dans un esprit
constructif et
d'écoute cela implique aussi que les
collectivités territoriales tout en
continuant d'investir maîtrisent leurs
dépenses mais nous ne reviendrons pas
mais nous ne reviendrons pas à l'idée
d'un mécanisme contraignant tel qui
figurit dans la première version de ce
projet de loi je vous le redis il n'y
aura pas de contrat de chaor BIS nous
faisons le Paris de la confiance avec
les collectivités territoriales nous
travaillons à une nouvelle méthode avec
les élus locaux notamment dans le cadre
du Haut Conseil des finances publiques
locales ces efforts partagé sur les
dépenses publiques ne doivent pas se
faire au au détriment du défi de la
transition écologique qui est devant
nous ni de la croissance la trajectoire
de finances publiques que nous vous
proposons tir aussi les conclusions
d'une année de travail sous l'égide de
la première ministre sur la
planification écologique nous sommes
confrontés à une double dette publique
et écologique la LPFP offre une vision
actualisée des crédit de l'État consacré
à la transition écologique en cohérence
avec l'investissement supplémentaire de
10 milliards d'euros annoncé par le
président de la République et la
première ministre qui se traduira par
une hausse des crédits de paiement de 7
milliards d'euros en
2024 la loi consacre l'obligation de
baisser le poids des dépenses néfaste à
l'environnement enfin notre trajectoire
vise à rendre le travail plus attractif
cela passe par la poursuite des baisses
d'impôts que nous avons engagé depuis
plusieurs années maintenant et qui se
sont traduites notamment par la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation et
de la redevance sur l'audiovisuel public
et par la baisse et par la baisse de 5
milliards de l'impôt sur le revenu à la
sortie de la crise des gilets jaunes il
ne faut poursuivre cette dynamique dans
les années à venir c'est pourquoi nous
engagerons une baisse de l'impôt pour
les ménages de 2 milliards d'euros dès
2025 pour conclure ce projet de LPFP est
un texte fondamental pour la crédibilité
budgétaire de la nation française ce
projet loi fixe des objectifs clairs
pour de 2027 le retour sous les 3 % de
déficit public précisément à 2,7 % et la
réduction de notre dette publique pour
revenir à 108,1 % contre 111,8 % en
2022 ce projet loi repose sur des choix
politiques simples et fort plus de
moyens pour s'attaquer à notre dette
écologique plus de croissance pour
engager le désendettement plus de
réformes pour réduire les dépenses plus
de travail pour offrir plus de
prospérité à nos compatriotes je vous
remercie pour votre
attention merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
Husson rapporteur de la commission des
finances monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre bienvenue mes chers
collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui en nouvelle
lecture le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à
2027 ce texte disonsle tout de suite un
parcours peu commun l'Assemblée
nationale l'a rejeté en première lecture
il y a 1 an puis le Sénat l' adopté en
novembre dernier en prévoyant une
trajectoire de rétablissement des
finances publiques plus ambitieuse que
celle qui était proposé par le
gouvernement la commission mixte
paritaire a échoué à parvenir à un
accord le 15 décembre
dernier puis le texte est entré dans une
sorte de sommeil le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre qui nous expliquait
et nous explique toujours d'ailleurs que
ce texte est essentiel n'a en réalité
rien fait pour tenter de trouver un
compromis malgré de nombreuses
déclarations d'intention c'est en effet
seulement à la fin du mois de septembre
c'est-à-dire 9 mois après l'échec de la
CMP que le gouvernement a demandé à
l'Assemblée nationale de se prononcer en
nouvelle lecture ce qu'elle n'a
véritablement pas eu le temps de faire
puisque le gouvernement a mis un terme
au débat en engageant sa responsabilité
pour faire adopter le texte sans vote en
application de l'article 493 de la
Constitution court circuitant ainsi les
débats devant l'Assemblée nationale vous
imposer monsieur le ministre un texte
qui ne paraît pas plus satisfaisant
qu'il ne l'était en première lecture
alors je commencerai d'abord par ce qui
est le fondement même d'une loi de
programmation des finances publiques à
savoir les hypothèses macro-économiques
et la trajectoire des finances publi les
prévisions macroéconomiques sur
lesquelles est assise la trajectoire de
votre gouvernement paraissent toujours
trop optimiste pour la seule année 2024
je rappelle que la prévision de
croissance du gouvernement est de 1,4 %
la Banque de France prévoit elle + 09 et
le consensus des économistes Plus+ 08
vos prévisions jusqu'en 2027 monsieur le
ministre reposent sur une combinaison
d'hypothèses toute favorable les
planètes s'aligneraient comme par
enchantement investissement élevé des
entreprises contribution positive du
commerce extérieur retour à un taux
d'épargne qui était celui d'avant-crise
et cetera et cetera mais Monsieur le
Ministre l'actualité internationale
récente nous indique pourtant encore une
fois à quel point en matière de
prévision économique la prudence et de
mise au-delà même d'ailleurs du manque
de crédibilité de ce scénario les
objectifs de déficit de votre texte
paraissait en desessà de ce qui est
nécessaire pour rétablir nos comptes
certes la cible est légèrement plus
ambitieuse que l'an dernier vous l'avez
dit avec un déficit à 2,7 points de PIP
pour 2027 mais le seuil des 3 % ne
serait pas atteint avant 2027 nous
serions ainsi le plus mauvais élèves de
l'Europe en quelque sorte le boneddane
et nous risquerions une procédure de
déficit excessif le texte du
Gouvernement qui est donc considéré
comme adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
n'a donc tenu aucun compte du vote du
Sénat en première lecture il n'a pas non
plus repris le vote du Sénat qui
alignait l'effort de redressement de
l'État sur celui des collectivités
territoriales hors mesure exceptionnelle
et en effet à part la suppression
bienvenue des nouveaux contrats de cor
dont nous nous réjouissons le texte
résultant du 493 est en substance le
retour à la copie initiale du
gouvernement autant vous le dire je le
déplore par ailleurs le texte qui nous
est transmis en nouvelle lecture porte
d'une certaine manière la marque d'une
improvisation ainsi aux articles 12 et
17 qui fixent les plafonds de dépenses
pour le budget de état et les objectifs
pour les administrations de sécurité
sociale le gouvernement ajouté en
nouvelle lecture de anila qui nous
interpelle en plus des dispositions
classiques contenues dans ces articles
et prévu par la LOLF c'est deux sortes
de verru semble dire écoutez ne tenez
pas compte des chiffres qui précèdent
nous ferons 6 milliards d'euros
d'économie en plus en 2025 2026 et 2027
sur chacune des deux catégories
d'administration publique après tout
pourquoi pas mais rien n'est dit sur
l'origine de ces économies il est en
particulier douteux monsieur le ministre
qu'elle puisse découler des revues de
dépenses qui n'ont été que très peu
productives cette année malgré je dirais
l'important de communication fait à leur
sujet il est également douteux qu'elle
soit conforme aux dispositions de la
LOLF et en tout état de cause elle nuise
considérablement à la clarté de notre
débat par ailleurs le gouvernement
inscrit ses économies théoriques en loi
de programmation tout en déposant je le
note tout de suite des textes financiers
pour 2024 qui voit la dépense publique
monsieur le ministre progresser de plus
2,2 % hors mesure de crise je dis bien
plus 2,2 % où sont les économies de même
votre version la loi de programmation
propose la stabilité des emplois de
l'État et de ses opérateurs alors
que le PLF 2024 prévoit 8200 postes
supplémentaires qui viennent s'ajouter
aux 11200 postes supplémentaires déjà
prévu en PLF 2023 en clair le
gouvernement ne tient pas les
engagements qu'il se propose à lui-même
à les comprendre monsieur le ministre à
force de ne pas faire ce que vous dites
de ne pas dire ce que vous faites non
seulement les comptes de la France ne
sont pas tenus mais les Français ne s'y
retrouvent pas vous ne priorisez rien en
annonçant d'ailleurs vouloir financer
tout ou presque à chaque jour une
annonce nouvelle dont l'unité de valeur
est souvent le milliard vous parlez de
sérieux budgétaire et vous faites
exploser la dette de la France tout en
renvoyant au parlementaires vous venez
de le faire encore la responsabilité de
faire des économies c'est le monde à
l'envers tout cela est d'ailleurs très
nuisible à notre société à l'heure où
les Français attendent des choix clairs
avec un cap cohérent définissant les
efforts à réalisés et les perspectives
d'amélioration attendu pour notre pays
et pour les Français eux-mêmes c'est
pourquoi la Commission des Finances n'a
pas simplement rejeté votre texte elle
l'a aussi modifié en nouvelle lecture et
en toute responsabilité
elle propose au Sénat d'adopter une
position claire et ambitieuse dans le
droitfil de son vote en première lecture
l'année dernière le texte qui vous est
proposé prévoit ainsi une diminution
annuelle en volume de 0,5 % des dépenses
des administrations centrales hors
charge de la dett et hors coût des
dépenses engagées pour faire face aux
crises ainsi l'effort de redressement de
l'État serait réel et non
essentiellement porté par la disparition
progressive et inéupable des mesures de
crise et surtout cet effort serait
équivalent à celui demandé par le texte
qui nous a été soumis pour les
administrations locale il permettrait
enfin de franchir le seuil d'un déficit
inférieur à 3 % du PIB dès 2025 et non
2027 outre cette trajectoire sur
plusieurs points nous avons quand
c'était opportun conserver les avancées
intervenu à l'Assemblée mais repris
également plusieurs modifications
adoptées en première lecture ici au
Sénat et qui avait disparu du texte
c'est notamment le cas pour l'évolution
de l'emploi public à l'article 10
encadrement des dispositifs d'aide aux
entreprises à l'article 15 la mise en
réserve de longam à l'article 19 et
l'évaluation de l'action publique à
l'article 21 vous insistez monsieur le
ministre sur la nécessité d'adopter
cette loi de programmation pour pouvoir
bénéficier des versements européens du
plan de relance comme si le contenu de
cette loi n'avait guerre d'importance
mais que seul son adoption formelle
compté je crois pour ma part à la veille
du de la 50
année consécutive de déficit budgétaire
de l'État français qu'il faut surtout
adopter un texte qui trace une véritable
perspective pour le rétablissement des
finances publiques et qui préserve les
marches de manœuvre dont nous avons tant
besoin pour financer en effet la
transition écologique les mutations
économiques la préservation de notre
modèle social et pour faire face à
toutes ces crises que le pays ne man
manquera pas de rencontrre à l'avenir je
souhaite donc que vous écoutiez la voix
du Sénat et les choix qu'il propose
monsieur le ministre après le rejet de
votre texte par l'Assemblée nationale
puis 1 493 le texte que nous vous
soumettons aujourd'hui est le seul je
dis bien le seul qui a été voté par la
représentation nationale ne pas en tenir
compte serait une faute
politique ne pas en tenir compte et
repasser en force avec le même texte en
493 l'Assemblée nationale serait une
erreur coupable ne pas en tenir compte
confinerait l'attitude du gouvernement
une forme d'entêtement aveugle refusant
d'entendre la voix de la raison qui
s'exprime au Sénat ne pas en tenir
compte consacrerait une réalité celle
d'un gouvernement qui ne veut pas
rétablir les comptes publ de la France
alors Monsieur le Ministre écoutez le
Sénat c'est à la fois une invitation et
un conseil amical je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
maintenant la Paro est à Monsieur claud
real président de la commission des
finances monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues l'examen
d'aujourd'hui 2e lecture de la loi
programmation des finances publiques
2023 à 2027 à un côté il faut bien le
reconnaître un peu
lunaire il y a 1 an commission mixte
paritaire non conclusive hier 2e lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale interrompu par
en
493 aujourd'hui 2e lecture au Sénat et
vote d'un texte qui devrait ressembler à
s'y méprendre à celui de la première
lecture puis sans doute un nouveau 493 à
l'Assemblée nationale où l'on pourra
mesurer les apports du Sénat je reste
cependant assez
dubitatif passons rapidement sur le fait
que le décaissement des crédits du plan
de relance européen serait lié à
l'adoption d'un projet de loi de
programmation même en admettant qu'elle
soit impérative ce dont il est permis de
douter cette condition découle du seul
engagement pris volontairement par le
gouvernement auprès de la commission
aucun autre pays européen n'a pris
d'engagement en ce sens ceci étant dit
nul doute que l'adoption d'une loi de
programmation reste reconnaissons-le un
outil utile elle permet de définir une
trajectoire budgétaire et théoriquement
les moyens pour la tenir comme disent
les marins il n'y a pas de bon vent pour
celui qui ne sait pas où il
va c'est justement la question monsieur
le ministre savez-vous où vous allez la
trajectoire que vous proposez est-elle
crédible par courtoisie je dois le dire
je n'évoquerai pas ici celle de la
majorité sénatoriale c'est de la
courtoisie
l'histoire nous a
appris que proposer de réduire le
déficit des finances publiques avec une
croissance faible qui plus est cela a
été dit très largement incertaine est
une gageure quant à la réalisation d'un
important montant d'économie le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques indique
sobrement que celles-ci ne sont pas
toujours documentées à ce jour et pour
cause en 2024 les économie repose
presque intégralement sur la diminution
des boucliers tarifaires et autres
indemnités
carburants à partir de 2025 il faudrait
donc trouver vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre de l'ordre de 12 milliards
d'euros d'économie nouvelle pendant 3
ans rien n'est dit sur le sujet et c'est
vrai que c'est assez pitoresque de voir
qu'on se retourne vers les
parlementaires pour finalement donner
corps à la promesse
gouvernementale je considère cependant
que mon rôle est de vous y
aider depuis 2020 et la crise du covid
je vous mets régulièrement en garde sur
une poursuite de la baisse des impôts
incompréhensible en période de
difficultés budgétaire le président de
la la Cour des comptes et le gouverneur
de la Banque de France ont porté des
constats identiques demandant à minima
que ces baisse soit gagé par des
diminutions de dépenses de même nature
ce qui n'a pas été le cas du coup voyez
l'enchaînement baisse annuel des impôts
de 38 milliards d'euros j'enlève la
baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés que
je partage augmentation parallèle de la
dette augmentation de fait du coût de la
dette et donc diminution en valeur
des dépenses budgétaires pour arriver à
l'équilibre résultat pour les ménages
suppression de la taxe d'hapitation pour
ceux qui l'a payé avec évidemment une
prime pour les hauts revenus je rappelle
que les 20 % les plus aisés se sont
répartis 10 milliards sur les 26 au
total aujourd'hui ce manque à gagneré
pour l'État est pris en charge par tous
et notamment les plus fragiles retraite
indemnité chômage de logement santé et
cetera vous l'avez décidé avant les
crises celle-ci devrait vous inciter à
revenir en arrière il est encore temps
pour les entreprises après une bête du
taux d'imposition de mon point de vue
peu contestable vous supprimez 8
milliards d'euros de CVE en finalement 5
ans au total pas d'intérêt car pas
d'effet de choc selon le MDF écoutz
finalement les entrepreneurs écoutz le
Parlement qui n'en voulait pas ne
vautt-il pas mieux garder les ressources
pour soutenir comme vous l'avez fait
utilement les entreprises en cas de
crise PGE chômage partiel plan de
relance enfin comme moi une partie de
cet hémicycle le pense n'est-il pas
temps pour certains de retrouver un
chemin plus vertueux pour nos finances
publiques et contribuer davantage au
patrimoine entreprises ayant bénéficié
des crises entreprises préférant
racheter leurs actions au bénéfice de
leurs actionnaires plutôt que d'investir
dans leur développement je le redis en
conclusion la plupart de vos décisions
initiales ont été prises avant les
crises il il est temps donc de se
reprendre et comme écrivait
Saint-Augustin dans les sermons eraré
ou monouest persévéraré
diabolic merci monsieur le Président
nous passons à la discussion de la
motion tendante à opposer la question
préalable Monsieur Pascal salbonelli
Éric Boquet et les membres du groupe
communiste républicain citoyens et
écologistes kanaki ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 1 tendant à
opposer la question préalable au texte
en discussion la parole est à Monsieur
Pascal
salvodelli monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les membres du groupe communiste
républicains citoyens écologistes et
kanaki proposent le rejet de cette loi
de programmation
et quatre raisons nous amènent à vous
inviter à faire le même choix que nous
cette loi de programmation imposée par
493 par le gouvernement puis ajusté par
la droite en deè lecture est en décalage
complet avec ce que vivent les habitants
de notre pays en décalage aussi avec ce
qu'il s'apprête à vivre dans les
prochaines années en ce sens elle est
injuste que ceux qui nous écoutent le
sache nous débattons d'un texte qui est
censé structurer les finances publiques
donc l'action publique pour les années à
venir pas une seule fois sont mentionnés
les mots
inégalité pas une seule fois sont
mentionné le mot
pauvreté personne n'en parle ni le
gouvernement qui a imposé ce texte par
un 493 à l'Assemblée ni la droite
sénatoriale qui a modifié le texte
comment peut-on être crédible avec un
tel manquement ce qui structure la vie
de notre pays aujourd'hui c'est bien les
inégalités sociales territoriales
environnementales c'est bien la vie chè
c'est bien le coût de l'électricité et
du du gaz une loi qui est donc en
décalage avec la réalité et pour cause
elle découle de l'article 3 du traité de
stabilité de coopération et de
gouvernance dont les grands principes
quelque peu amendés devant le principe
de rité ont été inchangés ont été
publiés pour la première fois en 2011
les règles budgétaires d'alors ont volé
en éclat depuis la crise sanitaire mais
aussi la guerre en Ukraine et la crise
climatique qui s'est accru on nous
demande donc d'appliquer des règles
budgétaires qui d'une part ont fait et
refait la démonstration de leur
efficacité j'en viens à la deuxième
raison cette loi est caduque et
inapplicable cela mes chers collègues
nous le savons tous très bien en effet
même l'initiateur de cet outil
budgétaire Nicolas Sarkozi n'a pas
réussi à respecter ses propres
prévisions j'en veux pour preuve depuis
2009 C lois de programmation ont été
adopté sur toute cette période en 14
années seul 2 années ont respecté la
prévision de déficit de plus les écarts
de prévision de croissance en volume ont
été en moyenne de 3,2 points de
pourcentage la croissance potentielle a
subi un écart d'un point en moyenne
inquiétant quand on sait que les
prévisions de cette programmation là se
situent à 1,35 %. cette trajectoire
financière ne fera pas exception elle
est frappée d'obsolescence programmé
elle est inapplicable et sera
inappliquée permettez-moi aussi un mot
sur les prévisions macro-économiques du
texte même le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques les a qualifié de très
optimistes le gouvernement n'en a pas
tenu compte des prévisions bien trop
optimistes pour être prises au sérieux
le gouvernement prévoit en effet une
évolution des dépenses en volume qui
demurera qui demeurera la plus dure du
21e sièc c'est-à-dire à 0,1 % taux le
plus faible quand antérieurement le taux
de 0,7 % justifiait le non remplacement
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux c'est le
témoignage des excès de rigueur que
porte le projet de l'exécutif et qui
constituera un affaiblissement durable
de nos services public inapplicable et
inappliqué car ni la version du
gouvernement ni la version issue de la
commission des fin
selon les prévisions celle-ci se
maintiendrait autour de 3,6 % cela fera
donc bondir à 74 milliards d'euros par
an les charg des intérêts de la dette
mais pourquoi toujours brandir
l'épouvantail de la dette si j'ose dire
à qui profite le crime il faut savoir
détention directe par les épargnants est
devenu marginal l'intermédiation du
système financier banque assurant
gestionnaire d'actifs s largement imposé
par ailleurs les nonrésidents détiennent
54 de notre dette et les trois pays qui
en détiennent le plus sont les le
Royaume-Uni paradis de la finance et
deux paradis fiscaux le Luxembourg et
les îles caillement nous nous soumettons
donc aux intérêts des seuls marchés
financiers au détriment de l'intérêt
général de la nation une soumission sous
forme de chantage de l'Union européenne
c'est la troisème raison d'être de cette
motion un chantage qui a été exprimé à
mainre reprise par le gouvernement je le
cite si vous ne votez pas cette loi de
programmation vous privz la France des
crédits européens mais monsieur le
ministre qui a fait le choix délibéré
d'inscrire le plan national de relance
et résilience envoyé à la commission par
le vote d'une loi de programmation ce ne
sont pas les oppositions parlementaires
c'est vous et ne vous en déplaire vous
n'avez pas de majorité sur ce texte ni à
l'Assemblée nationale que vous avez
privé de vote et vous avez pas ma
connaissance une majorité au Sénat on
verra et vos propos dans un courrier
adressé au rapporteur génér et que le
président de la Commission de finances
mon collègue et ami Claude relal nous a
transmis et que je remercie atteste de
l'ambigué de la situation je cite la non
adoption de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques pourrait bloquer non
seulement les versements de l'Union
européenne attendu en 2023 et 2024 soit
quand même la petite somme de 17,8
milliards d'euros mais je continue la
citation mais risquerait de bloquer la
suite de l'exécution du plan français
les versements associés soit 28
milliards un ch avantage d'autant plus
inacceptable que sur les 40,3 milliards
d'euros que recevrait la France elle en
rembourserait 66 milliards faute de
nouvelles ressources propres faute de
mise à contribution du capital le
gouvernement s'est engagé sur une
trajectoire austéritaire et sans soutien
parlementaire j'en viens à la 4è raison
de cette motion c'est la surenchère
austéritaire de la version modifiée en
2è lecture bien loin différencier des
politiques du gouvernement les apports
de collègues de la majorité sénatoriale
entérine et aggrave les choix politiques
votre différence avec le gouvernement
j'irais dire excusez-moi de la formule
monsieur le rapporteur général c'est la
concurrence libre ça ça vous va mais le
problème c'est qu'elle est
faussée le projet de la droite
sénatoriale est clair des économies de
40 milliards d'euros en 2027 le tout
reposant sur l'état avec une brutalité
sans nom une baisse de 3 milliards en
valeur de 2024 à 2025 soit beaucoup plus
en intégrant l'inflation ce plan met
particulièrement à contribution les
collectivités c'est en effet la
proposition de réduction des dépenses
réelles de fonctionnement des
collectivités en volume à - 0,5 % mais
comment vous allez expliquer au maires
là où les factures de gaz électricité
des collectivités ont augmenté de 30 à
voir 300 % et si on a besoin d'exemples
jeai les exemples quand le président du
groupe les républicains au Sénat
monsieur rotillot dit vouloir je le cite
mettre l'État au pain sec en vérité il
mettra les Français au pain racis et je
vais m'en expliquer en commission le
rapporteur général nous a expliqué
vouloir réduire les poids des agences de
l'État avec des économies sur les
personnels il propose de réduire de 5 %
les effectifs des fonctionnaires de
l'État et de ses opérateurs 5 % et ça
nous a été expliqué c'est 100000 empoid
public en moins c'est c'était
effectivement le droitfil du programme
d'un candidat qui a pas bien réussi
s'appelait François Fillon en 2017
qu'est-ce que cela signifie il y a trop
d'agent à la Banque de France pour aider
les particuliers en situation de ress
endettement il y a trop d'agents à Pôle
emploi pour lutter contre le chômage ou
engager une formation il y a trop
d'agents à l'Office national des forêts
pour lutter contre le feu et le
réchauffement climatique la vérité c'est
que derrière les beaux discours devant
les élus locaux la majorité sénatoriale
aurait pu voter la version du
gouvernement de cette loi comme elle a
d'ailleurs voté l'essentiel de ses
budgets conclusion cette motion a donc
quatre raisons d'être rejeter une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
injustes du gouvernement en décalage
total avec ce que viv bon nombre
d'habitants de notre pays rejeter une
loi déjà caduque et rendue
inapplicable rejeter un santage qui est
imposé au peuple français et aux
parlementaires que nous sommes et
rejeter aussi une réécriture en deuxiè
lecture franchement la France mérite
mieux elle mérite le progrès économique
elle mérite le progrès social elle
mérite le progrès démocratique d'une
nouvelle autonomie financière et fiscal
des collectivités apte à un nouveau
développement des services publics
locaux elle mérite le progrès écologique
et non pas seulement la régression
permanente au gré des bouleversements du
monde en somme cette motion est
profondément progressiste et responsable
et la responsabilité c'est aussi le
travail d'amendement dans l'hypothèse de
la non adoption de cette motion à la
lecture des amendements déposés par les
différents groupes notre motion
s'inscrit bien sûr dans la philosophie
des amendements de notre groupe mais
aussi je le crois dans celle des
amendements déposé par les sénateurs
socialistes et écologistes donner de la
force à cette motion à une perspec de
crret pour les années à venir c'est
aussi donner la voix à toutes celles et
tous ceux qu'il soi élu ou pas élu qui à
travers le pays appellent un nouveau
souffle de l'action publique je vous
remercie pour votre
attention merci Monsieur
Savoldelli quel est l'avis de la
commission alors ce ne sera pas une
surprise c'est un avis
défavorable la
Commission a fait un choix
différent c'est de se pencher à nouveau
sur le texte et de proposer une
trajectoire de redressement des finances
publiques j'entends le temps du progrès
mais il y a aussi le temps de la vérité
on peut continuer de cacher la vérité
mais plus longtemps on la cache ou plus
tard on s'attelle à redresser les
comptes et bien plus grandes seront les
plai les douleurs et peut-être les
colères et c'est parce que nous devons à
la fois répondre à ces
obligations qui sont au moins des
obligations morales et finalement à
certain courage d'affronter la Vérité et
la dureté des chiffres puis c'est aussi
peut-être de faire quand même confiance
à l'Europe je rappelle que l'Europe qui
aujourd'hui est la cause ou serait la
cause de tous les mots c'est la France
qui a été à l'initiative et dans les
membres fondateurs faut-il rappeler au
début des années 50 la réconciliation
franco-allemande la Communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier la
politique agricole commune nous devons
en être fi certes
depuis l'Europe a grandi et parfois
peut-être à une crise de croissance mais
il nous appartient aussi de continuer à
être un élément fort au sein de l'Europe
et si on veut peser si on veut être un
leader si on veut être un exemple il
vaut mieux avoir des comptes bien tenus
c'est mieux de donner la bonne direction
quand on est en tête de classe et
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs la
difficulté me semble-t-il de la loi de
programmation qui pose le gouvernement
c'est Dr rester le ban le bonedan de la
classe européenne nous ne pouvons pas
attendre 2027 et c'est parce que nous
avons fait le choix d'être responsable
que je le redis la vie est
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur
le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur moi je souhaite que le débat a
lieu je mets plutôt un avis défavorable
à votre motion de de ce qui me permet
peut-être de préciser une ou deux choses
d'abord sur les prévisions
macro-économiques la semaine dernière le
FMI a prévu 1,3 % de croissance nous
sommes à 1,4 % de croissance donc nous
sommes proches des prévisions de
croissance les plus récentes fait par
des organismes
extérieur et je rappelle que pour
l'année 2023 personne ne croyait à notre
prévision de 1 % de croissance à part le
président Claude renal
peut-être mais regardez les prévisions
de de la Banque de France qui avait été
faite pour 2023 donc on maintient cette
prévision et et quand vous citez Pierre
Moscovici le président du du Haut
Conseil il évoque des des
objectifs optimiste mais pas
inatteignable et j'en veux pour preuve
la dernière estimation du FMI deuxème
élément parler de cure austéritaire
c'est pas une cure d'austérité que l'on
propose c'est un ralentissement de la
croissance de la dépense publique moins
rapide que l'inflation et je le dis et
c'est probablement ce qui nous sépare de
la version qui sort de la commission des
finances du Sénat où nous considérons
que l'ajustement il est trop brutal il
est trop brutal sur sur la dépenses et
nous nous préférons des marches
raisonnables progressives tenable de
réduction de notre déficit public plutôt
que d'annoncer des dizaines de milliards
d'euros
d'économie sans expliquer concrètement
comment les faire donc nous tenons cet
équilibre entre l'investissement
l'investissement dans les services
public et vous l'avez vous l'avez redit
tout en réduisant progressivement notre
déficit public autant de raisons pour
lesquelles nous souhaitons que le débat
ait lieu cet
après-midi merci monsieur le ministre il
y a-t-il des explications de vote
je vais donc consulter le Sénat sur la
question préalable je rappelle que
l'adoption de cette motion entraînerait
le rejet du texte en
discussion qui est pour la
motion qui est contre la
motion qui
s'abstient la motion est
rejetée
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur remémi
Ferraud pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
j'intervenais déjà il y a un an au nom
de mon groupe sur ce texte
texte aujourd'hui à peine remagné si ce
n'est pour intégrer quelques nouvelles
données tenant compte de l'année écoulée
et surtout surtout pour essayer
d'envoyer des signes à la majorité
sénatoriale comme en témoigne votre
intervention monsieur le ministre en
ouverture de nos débats nous sommes donc
à nouveau ici dans cet
hémicycle parce qu'il faut bien une loi
de programmation des finances publiques
parce que visiblement le calendrier de
l'Assemblée nationale était favorable à
un 493 et aussi parce que le
gouvernement a fait lui-même du vote de
son texte une condition pour le
versement des aides européennes du plan
de relance alors l'adoption de la lpfe
figure en effet parmi les engagements
qui ont été pris par votre gouvernement
dans le cadre des 2e et 3e demandes de
paiement du plan national de relance et
de résilience le ministre de l'Économie
l'a lui-même écrit dans un courrier dont
nous avons tous reçu reçu une copie il y
a quelques jours ces versements plan de
relance européens sont conditionnés mais
chaque gouvernement a proposé ses
propres conditions à la commission
songez que l'Allemagne elle s'engage à
investir 1,5 milliards de route dans des
projets liés à l'hydrogène l'Espagne a
proposé un plan du même montant pour
favoriser l'attractivité de son réseau
ferroviaire public et le gouvernement
français s'engage à adopter une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
point l'adoption d'une loi comme
garantie donnée par le gouvernement
encore une fois c'est une marque de
manque de considération pour le rôle du
Parlement lui-même et ce texte sans
lequel nous devrions donc faire une
croix sur 18 milliards d'euros d'aide
nécessaire à nos finances publiques il
n'a été qu'à peine remagné depuis 1 an
un an de perdu pour rien ou presque son
orientation politique n'enregistre aucun
changement significatif il se
caractérise toujours par son cap libéral
se traduisant par la poursuite et
l'accroissement d'une démarche de
désarmement fiscal et de contraction de
la dépense
publique pour autant la trajectoire
proposée dans ce texte n'est pas
crédible reposant sur des hypothèses
extrêmement optimiste même si elles ne
sont pas inatteignables et proposant de
des réductions de déficit qui n'ont
jamais été réalisés ces dernières années
et qui ne pourront d'ailleurs être
atteintes qu'au prix d'une véritable
austérité et d'un risque de récession
économique vous l'avez dit vous-même
monsieur le ministre baisse des impôts
de production réforme des retraites
réforme de l'assurance chômage et
d'autres mesures de régression sociale
permettent cette loi de programmation en
réalité cela ne suffira même pas pour
atteindre vos
objectifs don vous dites qu'ils ne sont
pas une baisse des dépenses publiques
mais une augmentation inférieure à
l'inflation donc une baisse des dépenses
publiques réelles pour les Français il
faudra mener une politique très dure et
ce texte atteste donc une nouvelle fois
de votre obstination à poursuivre la
même politique alors qu'elle est dans
l'impasse le même cap alors que la
situation internationales les
incertitudes géopolitiques auxquelles
nous faisons face devrai obliger à plus
d'anticipation sur le coût de la dette a
commencé par l'annulation d'un certain
nombre de baisses d'impôt prévu car vous
nous dites moins d'impôt moins de
dépenses moins de déficit et une dette
maîtrisée cette vision répétée
inlassablement depuis 2017 a été
largement démentie par les faits les 500
milliards de recettes perdu en 10 ans
n'auront pas relancé la croissance et
auront agravé
les les problèmes du pays
appauvrissement de l'État impasse pour
financer la planification écologique
service publics en crise inégalité en
hausse dans un contexte d'inflation et
de baisse du pouvoir d'achat voilà les
défis que nous aurions ensemble à
relever s'ajoute un manque de soutien de
considération pour les collectivités
territorial auquel vous demandez de
ralentir leurs dépenses vous avez
renoncé à graver dans le marbre le pacte
de confiance c'est vrai mais sans
renoncer à l'idée la réalité qu'il n'y
aura avec cette perspective budgétaire
ni Pact ni confiance et que cela est
contraire à l'esprit de la
décentralisation et à l'équité dans la
répartition des efforts entre les
administration locale et l'État les
relations sont déjà dégradées entre
l'État et les collectivités
territoriales toutes les associations
d'élus en témoigne cela ne pourra
qu'empirer alors pour conclure la seule
question que devrait à mon avis se poser
ce texte c'est comment maîtriser les
finances publiques et garantir la
souveraineté de notre pays en étant
réaliste en étant équilibré dans l'EFF
en étant socialement juste en étant
écologiquement responsable et sans faire
chavirer le navire vous ne répondez pas
à cette question avec votre texte pire
encore vous attaquez au nombre de
fonctionnaires et chers collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale trouvez
bien raisonnable de surenchérir en
supprimant un poste ce fonctionnaire sur
20 d'ici
2027 donc nous vous proposerons une
quinzaine d'amendements notamment de
suppression des articles pour marquer
notre rejet de ce texte ni très réaliste
ni très raisonnable et dont je suis
convaincu qu'il s'avèera dépasser dès la
prochaine crise sociale je vous
remercie merci Monsieur fer la parole
est désormais à Madame che Lavarde pour
le groupe
[Applaudissements]
rublain monsieur le ministre j'ai relu
les propos que j'avais tenu dans cet
hémicycle l'année dernière pour le même
exercice donc gagnons du temps je ne
vais pas vous le répéter puisque j'ai le
sentiment que rien n'a changé même si
Rémy fignerud lui a vu des signes mais
malheureusement la majorité n'arrive pas
à les décrypter le monde change mais en
France rien ne change la dernière
édition du monitaire des finances
publiques du FMI je vois que vous lisez
aussi cette institution indique pourtant
clairement que l'action climatique va
contraindre les décideurs à des
arbitrages difficiles recourir
principalement et de manière croissante
à des mesures de dépenses pour atteindre
les objectifs de lutte contre le
changement climatique va se révéler de
plus en plus coûteux un endettement
élevé la hausse des taux d'intérêt et la
dégradation des perspectives de
croissance rendrant les finances
publiques de plus en plus difficiles à
équilibrer d'un côté opter pour le
statut quo rendrait le monde plus
vulnérable face aux effets du
réchauffement climatique dit autrement
les pouvoirs publics font face à un
trilème mettre en œuvre des mesures
faisables politiquement atteindre les
objectifs climatiques et assurer la
viabilité des finances publiques je n'ai
pas le sentiment malheureusement que
cette loi de programmation prenne la
mesure de ce trilemme la trajectoire de
solde public assise sur des hypothèses
très optimistes comme l'a rappelé
rapporteur général prévoit seulement un
niveau de de déficit de 2,7 points en
2027 le Haut Conseil souligne d'ailleurs
le poids croissant de la charge des des
charges d'intérêt par ailleurs
l'objectif de 2027 suppose d'importantes
économies structurelles en dépenses qui
ne sont absolument pas documenté alors
votre gouvernement indique qu'elles
pourront être précisé à à l'issue d'un
exercice de revue de la dépense
parlons-en cette revue de la dépense et
de l'évaluation de la qualité de la
dépense publique la loi de programmation
prévoit un dispositif d'évaluation sur
la base d'une évaluation annuelle
thématique alors un premier exercice
s'est déroulé au cours du 1emier
semestre 2023 et a fait l'objet d'un
rapport au Parlement alors disons-le
nous les 12 premières missions étudiées
sont de nature très varié et d'enjeux
très varié puisque sur le même plan on a
la politique du logement et les dépenses
de nuité hôelière de l'hébergement
d'urgence permettez-moi de voir de dire
qu'on n'est pas exactement sur la même
assiette de dépenses alors la Cour des
comptes elle aussi a choisi de se saisir
de ce sujet et elle a complété les
travaux avec neuf notes thématiques qui
ont été publié au mois de juillet là
encore la politique du logement a été
étudié et c'est dans le dans la droite
ligne des propos du président moscovicii
qui devant les sénateurs a préconisé de
lever le capot de la dépense publique
alors quels sont les effets de ces
premiers rapports ben moi je vais vous
le dire tout de suite rien du tout un
seul exemple le Fond national d'action
sociale de la branche famille la
conclusion des travaux a déclenché l'ire
des élus locaux et ainsi le 1er octobre
l'Association des maires de France alors
je sais pas si on doit dire t x enfin
vous me comprenez après l'alerte de la
MF sur la décision de diminuer en 2023
puis de supprimer à la rentrée 2024 le
fond de soutien aux activités
périscolaires ellisabeth born m'a fait
savoir que les crédits pour 2023-2024
seraient rétablis pour la rentrée 2024
la MF fera des propositions donc autant
dire 6 mois de travail pour rien alors
ces travaux pourraient utilement être
complétés par ceux du Conseil d'État qui
dans son étude annuelle publiée au début
du mois de septembre nous invite à
étudier les politiques publiques non pas
seulement avec les lunettes de celui qui
les fait mais aussi avec les lunettes de
l'usager et donc étudier les politiques
publiques avec un impératif de proximité
et de pragmatisme 2uxième champ qui doit
faire l'objet d'évaluation pour venir
diminuer la dépense publique celui des
dépenses fiscales alors là aussi pour
une meilleure information du Parlement
l'exécutif devra remettre annuellement
une liste des niches fiscales arrivant à
échéance ainsi que un évaluation des
dépenses non bornées alors tout ça ce
sera très certainement pour le PLF 2025
parce que j'ai toujours pas trouvé de
document pour le PLF 2024 et j'ai encore
chercher il y a quelques instants mais
au-delà de tout ça il conviendrait de
définir ce qu'est une dépense fiscale
dans le présent PLF dans le tome 2 des
voisin moyen pas moins de 5 pages pour
essayer de nous expliquer de quoi on
parle alors en effet la norme actuelle
est très floue comment expliquer que le
taux de TVA à 10 % sur la qutine
d'entreprise est une dépense fiscale
quand la TVA à 5,5 % sur la cantine
scolaire ne l'est pas par ailleurs ces
dépenses fiscales elles n'ont pas de
responsable au sens des responsables de
programme de la LOLF ce sont en fait des
dépenses de guichet alors la dernière
revue systématique des dépenses fiscales
elle remonte à 2011 et elle faisait
suite à une inscription dans la LPFP de
2009 et à l'époque 315 dépenses avaient
été analysé alors depuis 10 ans et la
Cour des comptes l'a encore relevé dans
son dernier rapport sur le budget de
l'État pour 2022 toutes les idées de
d'évaluation sont restées lettrre mortes
et ce PLF ne fait pas excep extion sur
les 467 dépenses listées seul 403 sont
chiffrés dont 129 avec un ordre
grandandeur dit autrement 41% des
dépenses fiscales sont mal connues alors
comme la présente loi de programmation
prévoit de réduire leur limite à 3 ans
il va falloir dès maintenant commencer
le travail d'évaluation sinon on on ne
risque pas d'être prêt à l'heure et je
vous parlerai au prochain épisode de
l'évaluation du budget climatique parce
que là aussi il y aura beaucoup à dire
merci Madame
Lavarde pour les nonincrits monsieur
zure pour 3 minutes c'est à
vous monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances mes chers collègues si elle ne
constitue aucune contrainte normative ni
pour le gouvernement ni pour le
Parlement cette loi de programmation
permet d'apprécier ou pas les choix qui
s'imposeront français pour les années à
venir ce qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui ne montre aucune remise en
cause du modèle politique actuel nous
sommes ici dans la continuité de ce qui
ne marche pas et à nouveau dans le refus
des évidences c'est déjà le sens de ce
qu'a imposé le gouvernement par le biais
du 493 à l'Assemblée nationale ça n'est
pas beaucoup moins le sens de ce que
propose la version sénatoriale mes chers
collègues nous ne pouvons pas nous
soumettre en permanence aux in aux
injonctions pardon de bruxel nous ne
pouvons pas aller chercher nos économies
sur le financement des collectivités
territoriales et de leur projets ou sur
le droit de nos compatriotes à profiter
de leur retraite après une vie de
travail nous ne pouvons pas aller
chercher nos économies sur des bouts de
chandell pour l'État qui sont en
revanche des coups de poignard dans le
dos de nos compatriotes comme la fin des
avantages fiscaux pour le GNR véritable
trahison à l'égard de nos agriculteurs
et un grand nombre d'entreprises
monsieur le rapporteur vous disiez il y
a quelques temps à juste titre que le
gouvernement n'opérait aucun virage
structurel mais je regrette que la
majorité sénatoriale préserve certains
totem les parlementairesenes défendent
d'autres priorités nous défendons la
baisse de la contribution nette que
verse la France à l'Union européenne
nous défendons la lutte contre la fraude
sociale la vraie celle par exemple
contre les 3 millions de fauses carte
vital en circulation nous défendons la
priorité nationale et la lutte contre
l'immigration légale comme illégale à la
fois pour des raisons économiques et
sociales mais fatalement de plus en plus
aussi pour des raisons sécuritaires
comme l'actualité nous l'a tristement
rappelé nous défendons la taxation des
super profits comme une mesure de
justice fiscale et sociale nous
défendons la suppression des agences
d'État parmi celles qui ont le plus
prouvé la inutilité nous défendons un
rééquilibrage territorial et une
redirection des moyens en faveur de
certains territoires confisqués de la
République vers nos communes notre
ruralité et nos agriculteurs qui eux ne
peuvent faire l'objet d'aucune cure
d'austérité loin de l'omô annoncé dans
le PLF 2024 d'une augmentation de 220
millions de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement loin de seulement
dénoncer une mauvaise gestion des
donniers publiques par le gouvernement
nous dénonçons des aberrations
politiques économiques et sociales qui
n'ont que trop duré et qui confirment
avant tout que le le gouvernement est
incapable de changer de logiciel par
conformisme et par manque de courage le
Sénat peut jouer un autre rôle que celui
de limiter les pocassés des mauvaises
politique présidentielle il peut
proposer une voie alternative complète
pour ces raisons nous nous opposons donc
à cette loi de programmation des
finances publiques je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Zurek la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Emmanuel Capu
pour le groupe Les
Indépendants
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mes chers collègues nous sommes bientôt
en 2024 donc plus le temps passe moins
ce texte est d'actualité et pourtant son
adoption demeure nécessaire
l'instauration des lois de programmation
pour les finances publiques est une
avancée positive qui date du quinquena
de François Hollande c'est suffisamment
rare mes chers collègues pour être
souligné c'est suffisamment rare pour
être souligné mes chers collègues cet
objet vise à dessiner une trajectoire
sur 5 ans pour nos finances publiques il
s'agit d'une prévision qui ne
contraindra pas les futurs débats
budgétaires nous serons chaque année
libre de nous y tenir ou de nous en
écarter et cela vaut pour le
gouvernement comme pour le
Parlement mais est-ce que ce caractère
non contraignant rend cet objet sans
valeur je ne le crois pas je vois pour
ma part trois bonnes raisons de
l'adopter la première raison c'est une
raison de temporalité l'objectif d'une
loi de programmation c'est de fixer dès
le début du quinquena une trajectoire
pour nos finances publiques comme je le
disais plus le temps passe moins la
prévision est engageante et moins le
texte est d'actualité c'est pourquoi je
me réjouis que son examen soit de
nouveau à l'ordre du jour en vue d'une
adoption prochaine par le
Parlement la deuxième raison tient à une
question de principe
adopter cette loi de programmation c'est
bien sûr trouver un point d'équilibre
politique mais c'est aussi envoyer un
message à nos partenaires européens et
aux institutions financières sauf à ce
que quelqu'un trouve d'ici la fin de
l'année une solution pour effacer d'un
coup d'un seul la dette publique de la
France il est important de veiller à
notre crédibilité sur la scène
internationale et pour ce faire il est
indispensable de trouver un accord
politique sur cette loi de
programmation la trè et dernière raison
vaut 18 milliards d'euros c'est le
montant des deè et 3è paiement que la
France attend encore du plan de relance
européen leur versement est conditionné
par l'adoption de cette loi de
programmation le plan de relance
européen a permis à tous les
étatsmembres de limiter l'impact de la
crise sanitaire il a impulsé une forte
dynamique au plan économique et au plan
politique nous contenter d'une lecture
comptable reviendrait à l'ignorer
il serait irresponsable de laisser des
querelles politiciennes nous priver de
ressources aussi
conséquentes pour tout toutes ces
raisons justifie donc l'adoption de ce
texte sur la forme reste le fond mes
chers collègues je le dis sans ambigué
monsieur le ministre notre groupe
soutient ce texte sur certains points
nous proposons d'en relever l'ambition
par exemple sur la réduction des
effectifs de l'État nous l'avions déjà
fait adopter en première lecture
monsieur le rapporteur général je me jou
que cette mesure figure dans le texte en
nouvelle lecture en tout état de cause
je remercie le rapporteur général et le
président de la de notre commission
d'evrer à l'adoption de ce texte et de
débattre aujourd'hui au-delà des
divergences politiques je crois que
c'est important pour le fonctionnement
de notre démocratie et pour préparer
l'avenir de notre pays le Sénat mes
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
encore une fois est au rendez-vous du
débat merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur
Capu la parole estant est maintenant à
Monsieur Vincent deaet pour le groupe
Union
centriste monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
voudrais d'abord souhaiter la bienvenue
au Sénat monsieur le ministre
j'espère monsieur le ministre que vous
resterez en poste un peu plus longtemps
que votre prédécesseur parce que 14 mois
pour moi c'est beaucoup trop court et ce
départ prématuré démontre que le
redressement des finances publiques
n'est malheureusement pas une priorité
pour le
gouvernement et je vais me permettre de
vous faire le même cadeau qu'à vos
prédécesseurs les vertus de
l'équilibre c'est mon livre écrit en
2020 qui reste malheureusement
d'actualité et qui risque de le rester
longtemps j'espère que vous prendrez le
temps de le lire mais si je devais le
résumer en deux idées je ce serait que
les pays qui sont à l'équilibre
budgétaire ou en excédent ça existe a
quand même un certain nombre sont en
meilleure santé économique que
nous et la deuxième idée c'est que la
rigueur est une qualité indispensable
pour bien gérer l'argent public et elle
n'est pas impopulaire contrairement à
l'idée largement répandue cette rigueur
n'est pas incompatible avec le cœur et
c'est l'alliance de la rigueur et du
cœur qui fait une bonne
politique je voudrais profiter de mon
intervention pour dénoncer les anneries
entendues sur les finances publiques qui
n'aident pas nos compatriotes à y
comprendre quelque chose d'un côté à
gauche on n'arrête pas de dénoncer le
retour de
l'austérité c'est sûr que ça fait peur
et on aime bien faire
peur mais ce retour à l'austérité on le
dénonce sans définir ce qu'est l' vérité
et sans nous dire quand elle a été
appliquée en France depuis 50 ans alors
mes chers collègues je vais vous faire
gagner du temps elle n'a jamais été
appliquée depuis 50 ans et de l'autre
côté le ministre de l'Économie présente
un budget soi-disant à l'euro près après
avoir emprunté 800 milliards en 6
ans autre anerie incompréhensible le
même ministre déclare qu'il faut
accélérer le désendettement alors que
l'on a même pas démarrer chacun sait que
pour accélérer il faut déjà avoir
démarré et que il prévoit en 2024 de bar
de battre le record des
emprunts alors venons-en à cette loi de
programmation j'interviens pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste je salue les
collègues et donc je vais d'abord vous
dire pourquoi le groupe de l'Union
centriste va voter cette loi de
programmation la première raison c'est
ça a été pas mal dit c'est pour garantir
que la France puisse bénéficier du fond
de plan du plan de relance européen à la
mise en œuvre duquel elle a grandement
contribué l'absence de lois de
programmation pourrait risquerait nous
ditons le ministre de l'Économie l'a
même écrit risquerait donc de faire
peser un risque sur de versement
européens d'un montant de 18 milliards
d'euros pourtant en matière budgétaire
il est rare que les règles européennes
soi
appliqué nous n'avons jamais respecté
les critères de Maastrich et nous nous
avons empilé les déficits excessifs sans
que Bruxelles n'ose recourir au panel de
sanction prévu à cet effet mais dans le
doute le groupe Union centriste préfère
assurer la deuxième raison pour laquelle
le groupe votera ce cette loi de
programmation c'est que la version que
le Sénat devrait voter sera plus
volontariste avec deux orientations
fortes s'agissant de la trajectoire des
finances publiques que notre groupe
approuve tout d'abord le retour à un
déficit public en dessà du seuil des 3 %
du PIB dès 2025 au lieu de 2027 dans la
copie du gouvernement et la nécessité
d'effort de redressement budgétaire
identique pour les collectivités locales
et pour l'État hors mesure
exceptionnelle de crise voilà donc les
deux raisons pour lesquelles le groupe
votera et je voudrais maintenant vous
développer pourquoi à titre personnel je
ne voterai pas cette loi de
programmation
il y a au moins trois raisons
principales la première c'est toujours
des prévisions très optimistes monsieur
le ministre en matière de prévision
budgétaire non seulement il fera beau
demain mais il fera beau dans les 5
prochaines
années ainsi au seul titre de l'année
2024 le gouvernement prévoit une
croissance presque deux fois plus élevée
que le consensus des économistes j'ai
bien entendu le FMI on verra à l'arrivée
mais le consensus des économies c'est
0,8 aujourd'hui et vous êtes à 1,4 %
la deuxième raison pour laquelle je ne
voterai pas c'est que les efforts
indispensables pour redresser nos
finances publiques soit n'existent pas
soit sont reportés en fin de période
soit ne pèsent que sur les collectivités
soit le tout à la fois tout cela n'est
pour moi pas crédible et la troème
raison c'est que les budgets 2024 qui
nous ont déjà été
présentés prouve que les engagements du
gouvernement dans le présent projet de
loi ne sont dans la pratique pas
tenu la dépense publique n'est pas
maîtrisée mais
augmentée encore de 47 milliards en 2024
47 milliards mes chers collègues vous
vous rendez compte augmentation de la
dépense publique l'emploi de l'État et
de ses opérateurs augmentera de plus de
8000 postes en 2024 alors même que
l'article 10 du présent projet de
loi parle de stabilité des
effectifs donc que monsieur le ministre
je vois qu'il me reste un petit peu de
temps les économies les économies c'est
pas des dépenses exceptionnell qu'on ne
reconduit pas une année suivante ce ne
sont pas des économies quand on achète
une voiture si on ne rachète pas une
voiture l'année suivante on peut pas
considérer qu'on a fait des
économies les les vraies économies il y
en a plein il y en a beaucoup vous
pouvez lire nos documents vous lirez
dans mon ouvrage vous avez beaucoup de
projets alors beaucoup de sujets en
matière de gestion de l'argent public on
devrait avoir de règle intangible la
prudence dans la prévision et la rigueur
dans l'exécution je regrette que l'on
ait ni l'une ni
l'autre merci de votre
attention merci Monsieur
del la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Thomas Dosu pour 4 minutes du groupe
écologiste solidarité et
territoire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'était mon
collègue Daniel bryet qui intervenait en
première lecture et je vais m'inscrire
dans ses propos tant le texte n'a que
peu évolué depuis ces propos prévoir et
construire les trajectoires budgétaires
de notre pays pour les années qui
viennent est un exercice démocratique
important pourtant la lecture de ce
texte donne assez peu d'espoir sur
l'avenir de notre pays que ce soit pour
le gouvernement ou pour la majorité
sénatoriale ce texte est l'illustration
d'un double dénis qui fragilise notre
destin commun sur les question
écologique le compte n'y est pas et il y
a dans ce texte donc un affaiblissement
profond de la parole de la France la
France qui a su montrer la voie avec les
accord de Paris renit sa parole quand il
faut les mettre en
acte alors qu'elle a pris des nouveaux
engagements climatiques européens avec
l'ambition de réduire d'ici à 2030 de 50
% ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre
elle oublie ici qu'elle doit
provisionner les investissements publics
suffisants pour leur réalisation et la
marche est haute le mur d'investissement
public et privé pour atteindre nos
objectifs est colossal et on le sait
aussi plus nous attendons pour agir plus
ce montant grimpera et s'il y a une
dette qu'on ne rembourse pas c'est la
dette climatique nous aurions dû voir
apparaître ici la trajectoire financière
qui en découle et ce n'est pas le cas
nous sommes largement en dessous des
besoins c'est assez symptomatique
symptomatique de la dissonance française
sur la question d'un côté un secrétariat
général à la planification qui pourrait
construire un scénario de décarbonation
secteur par secteur et de l'autre une
programmation des finances publ qui qui
regarde l'avenir avec les seules
lunettes comptables et ignore la
globalité des besoins d'un côté un
ministre de l'écologie qui plaide pour
l'adaptation de la France à une
trajectoire à + 4 degrés et de l'autre
un ministre des comptes publiques qui
n'intègre pas cette impérieuse nécessité
d'adaptation dans sa trajectoire
budgétaire à long terme en refusant
d'agir à la hauteur ce sont les
générations futures que nous condamnons
par notre inaction nous avons besoin
d'une programmation pluriannuelle des
financements de la transition écologique
afin de réellement planifier de
sécuriser les moyens nécessaires aux
transformations profondes de notre
société et d'offrir des perspectives
claires à notre économie si l'on parle
d'écologie alors il faut aussi parler
des acteurs majeurs de sa mise en œuvre
les collectivités territoriales
l'attitude de l'État à leur égard les
inquiète si la crise notamment
énergétique les frappe durement il en
est de même pour la suppression de leur
léviers fiscaux comme la CVE ou le
corsetage de leur dépenses de
fonctionnement écologie collectivité
mais aussi santé avec une contrainte
extrêmement forte sur l'ondâ c'est tout
le champ du bien public qui est
contraint limité restreint par une
vision idéologique des finances public
partagé entre le gouvernement et la
majorité sénatoriale à ceci près que la
majorité sénatoriale a rajouté un coup
de rabau budgétaire supplémentaire à ce
texte et pas des moindres un objectif de
réduction des emplois publics de 5 % en
équivalent temps plein oui au moment où
nous avons tant besoin d'une république
en acte dont les agents publics doivent
se sentir soutenus la droite sénatoriale
propose un plan social d'ampleur chez
celles et ceux qui la font vivre dans le
contexte actuel c'est assurément
assurément un désarmement de notre
République auquel nous ne pouvons
adhérer pour autant la situation n'est
pas inextlicable les ressources
potentielles sont là elles existent de
nouvelles contributions que l'on
pourrait mettre en œuvre sur le
patrimoine des plus riches ou sur les
profits énormes des grandes entreprises
souvent polluantes qui ont honteusement
profité de la crise une extinction de
des niches fiscal antiécologique fléché
vers des mesures de soutien pour les
actifs pour les ménages et pour les plus
fragiles voici quelques pistes concrètes
les besoins mais aussi les leviers comme
les sources de financement sont connues
et pourtant texte après texte budget
après budget la même déception le même
constat d'échec la transition n'est
toujours pas au rendez-vous et le
service le service public est de plus en
plus affaibli un double déniis toujours
présent dans ce texte c'est pourquoi
comme en première lecture nous ne
voterons pas ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances
publiques merci Monsieur Dosu la parole
est maintenant à monsieur Éric boet pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologiste kanaki et ce pour 4
minutes bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général monsieur
le président de la commission des
finances monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues André conte ponville lors d'un
débat au 4 3e Congrès des Maires trouver
les mots justes je le cite je suis
convaincu qu'il y a un bonheur d'être
maire au moins un bonheur attendu un
bonheur espéré attention cela ne veut
pas dire que vous êtes heureux mais cela
veut dire que vous êtes maire pour être
heureux fin de citation à la lecture de
ce projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques les élus locaux
s'éloignent considérablement du bonheur
la raison est simple et é énoncé
clairement les collectivités
territoriales contribueront à l'effort
de réduction du déficit public et de
maîtrise de la dépense publique c'est
inscrit en toute lettre dans ce projet
de programmation les collectivités
territoriales sont donc mises au Pin Sec
pour reprendre la très inquiétante
formule du président retaillot pourtant
la majorité sénatoriale apporte son
soutien aux articles 13 et 16 le premier
l'article 13 ne prévoit ni plus ni moins
qu'une baisse de 2,55 milliards d'euros
constant des concours financiers de
l'État qui représente 50 % des
transferts financiers que perçoivent nos
collectivités 5 5,8 % de moins en volume
une bouchée de pain peu importe que dès
la première année de programmation entre
le texte initial et la nouvelle version
1,8 milliards supplémentaires sont
prévus attestant ainsi de l'obsolescence
programmé de cette loi de programmation
vous me direz que c'est moins que les
4,5 milliards d'euros de rabot du texte
initial mais je ne connais pas dans mon
département du Nord des Maes qui
n'expliquent ne pouvoir se passer du
moindre euro vous disiez dans votre vre
propos monsieur le ministre vouloir
faire confiance aux élus locaux
commencez donc par les écouter nous leur
dirons partout dans nos départements que
vous leur faites rembourser la dette
publique au mépris des réalités
financières locales le second l'article
16 inscrit une baisse 05 % des dépenses
réelles le fonctionnement des
collectivités en volume par année la
majorité sénatoriale là non plus ne dit
rien à qui es prend acte et vote elle
allège légèrement le fardeau des
départements en excluant quelquesunes
des dépens contrainte non sans une
certaine ambigué elle se félicite que
cet objectif ne soit plus contraignant
nous nous sommes battus pour la
suppression du retour des contrats de
Chor véritable pacte de défiance envers
les collectivités locales qui avaient
déjà frappé 322 communes lors du
précédent quinquena ce côté-là de
l'hémicycle ce borne a demandé que
l'effort de l'État soit au moins aussi
important que celui des collectivité la
position politique que vous adoptez est
là aussi très simple l'austérité nen
déplaise notre ami Vincent de la haie
pour toutes les administrations
publiques l'État les collectivités et la
sécurité sociale n'y a-t-il pas un
ranchérissement des taux d'intérêt dû au
ressirement de la politique de la Banque
centrale européenne n'y a-t-il pas une
augmentation des financements de la
banque des territoir du fait de
l'indexation des prêts sur les taux du
livra justement mais insuffisamment
majoré les collectivités souffrent dans
leur capacité de financement mais ell
devrai réduire encore leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement se débrouiller seul
encore
pourtant les témoignages que j'ai
entendu dans le Nord pendant les
élections sénatoriales comme beaucoup
d'entre vous chers collègues mais que je
lis également dans le rapport de
l'Observatoire des finances locales sont
incompatibles avec ces restrictions à
venir les achats et charges externes ont
ont bondi de 8,8 % après déjà 5,6 en
2021 en 2022 la situation arrêtée est
connue et grave l'énergie électricité
c'est plus 22 % pour les communes de
plus de 500 habitants les combustibles
et carburants c'est plus 29 %
l'alimentation c'est + 10 % après 24,7
voilà qui justifierait pleinement
l'adoption de nos amendements de
suppression qui vous seront soumis les
transports c'est plus 28 % après 19 % en
2021 l'évolution obligatoire du point
d'indice pour protéger les agents de la
fonction publique en particulier
territoriale marquera encore une fois
une mauvaise nouvelle groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste et kanaki
s'opposera à ce texte qui valide
l'impasse financier des collectivités et
en le bonheur des élus locaux et de leur
population merci Monsieur bouquet la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Christian Billac pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 4
minutes sur le
président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers
collègu monsieur le ministre nous allons
bientôt commémorer le 50e budget de la
France en
déficit nous pourrions célébrer cet
événement en nous gargarisant de notre
expertise en la matière et en la faisant
partager aux autres pays de l'Union
européenne et pourquoi pas au-delà ne
soyons pas modeste
plus sérieusement enné après anné les
déficits creusent nous avons dépassé le
seuil des 250 milliards d'emprunt pour
le budget de l'État et à ce rythme nous
passerons bientôt le cap des 300
milliards au cours de la discussion du
projet de loi de finances pour les
années 2023 2027 le remboursement de la
dette sera le premier poste budgétaire
de l'État devant la défense et devant
l'éducation
nationale ce texte a l'ambition de
ramener le déficit sous le seuil de 3 %.
mais pour ma part je continue à
considérer ce chiffre de 3 % comme
absurde pour ne pas dire ridicule car
c'est un minima vers l'équilibre
budgétaire qu'il nous faut tendre le
plus rapidement possible à l'examen de
ce texte je fais plusieurs constats
premièrement un manque d'ambition en
matière de réduction des déficits de
notre pays deuxièmement des prévisions
macroéconomiques retenu par le
gouvernement qui sont considérés comme
optimistes par tous les analystes
troisièmement un int insuffisant du
principal responsable de la situation
actuelle à savoir l'état qui fait porter
aux organismes de sécurité sociale et
aux collectivités locales l'essentiel de
l'effort
budgétaire
certains pointent du doigt le taux des
prélevements obligatoires ce n'est pas
l'aspect le plus critiqué par les
Français car nos concitoyens arent tous
à la déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen qui dans son article 13
précise que pour l'entretien de la force
publique et pour les dépenses
d'administration une contribution
commune est indispensable elle doit être
également répartie entre tous les
citoyens en raison de leur faculté mais
après l'article 13 vient l'article
14 et je cite tous les citoyens
ont droit de constater par eux-mêm ou
par leurs représentants la nécessité de
la contribution publique de la consentir
librement d' suivre l'emploi et d'
déterminer la cotité l'assiette le
recouvrement et la durée c'est là que le
bblesse car nos concitoyens sont tout à
fait disposés à payer des impôts ou à
verser des cotisations sociales si leur
participation financière est utilisé à
boncien et avec
effiscalité supprimer des effectifs dans
la fonction publique ne veut selon moi
rien dire car les Français sont attachés
à la fonction publique et demande à
juste raison plus de fonctionnaires dans
la santé et en particulier dans les
hôpitaux dans l'éducation
nationale dans les
tribunaux mais aussi au sein des forces
de police et de gendarmerie or il
constate que parallèlement à
l'augmentation de leur contribution les
effectifs des fonctionnaires de
proximité diminuent pendant que les
effectifs ne cessent d'augmenter dans
les administrations central et chez les
opérateurs c'est là que nous devons agir
avec deux axes essentiels d'une part en
fixant un taux maximal pour les dépenses
de l'administration afin qu'un maximum
de contribution soit affecté au services
opérationnel d'autre part en supprimant
chaque année 10 % des opérateurs agence
au Conseil comité Théodule dont
l'efficacité n'est pas démontrée pour
conclure je m'abstiendrai sur ce texte
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que la
non adoption d'e no programmation semble
compromettre le versement d' européenne
enfin car si je suis favorable à la
réduction des déficites je la trouve
trop modéré trop timoré à l'absence de
réforme du millefeuille lequel
millefeuille s'il est composé de strat
territorial et surtout coiffé par la
croûte
administrative merci Monsieur B je vous
invite les uns et les autres quand même
à essayer de respecter la fourchette
temporelle Monsieur Didier Rambo pour le
rassemble le groupe des rassemblements
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues après le dépôt de ce texte en
septembre 2022 nous voici à nouveau
réunis presque un an plus tard pour
examiner le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 créé en 2008
par la réforme constitutionnelle la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
est un instrument qui permet qui prévoit
des outils de planification et
d'évaluation par le Parlement elle
permet également de limiter les dépenses
fiscales et sociales mais aussi de
s'assurer de la stabilité des schémas
d'emploi mais derrière ces objectifs
financiers économiques et sociaux il
s'agit également d'un enjeu de
crédibilité au niveau européen
si nos avis divergent bien souvent sur
les trajectoires de désendettement
accordons-nous cependant sur une chose
nous devons doter la France d'une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
loin d'être un détail c'est une
nécessité surtout si notre pays souhaite
bénéficier du plan national de relance
et de résilience je rappelle que la
France pourra encore recevoir près de 18
milliards d'euros de subvention dans le
cadre de ce plan au titre de la facilité
pour la reprise et de la résilience
adoptée en réponse à la CR crise du
covid sans oublier les 2,8 milliards
d'euros dans le cadre de de l'instrument
power eu adopté en réponse à la crise
énergétique par conséquent je considère
en effet qu'il est capital d'adopter une
loi de programmation ne prenons pas de
risque inutile avec la Commission
européenne qui pourrait bloquer les
versements financiers dont je parlais
précédemment des milliards d'euros qui
sont bel et bien conditionnés au respect
de nos engagements j'ai bien écouté vos
arguments monsieur le président Claude
renal en commission et si les menaces
que nous voyons se profiler sont au
conditionnels je nous suggère mes chers
collègues de ne pas jouer avec le feu
prendre le risque de ne pas adopter une
loi de programmation pluriannuelle en
matière de finances publiqu serait une
menace réelle pour la crédibilité de
notre pays comme l'a indiqué récemment
le rapporteur général du budget à
l'Assemblée nationale Jean-René
Caseneuve le Parlement a adopté des lois
de programmation dans les domaines
régaliens comme l'armée ou encore la
justice il n'y a donc aucune raison de
ne pas adopter une loi de programmation
en matière de finances publiques si les
débats existent en matière de
trajectoire budgétaire à propos de la
méthode je tiens pourtant pour pour
autant à rappeler que le gouvernement
agit pour réduire la dépenses publiques
et diminuer l'endettement de la France
comme son déficit monsieur le rapporteur
général j'ai lu attentivement votre
excellent rapport mais je ne peux
m'empêcher de relever que vous y vous y
déplorz je cite l'absence de prise en
compte par le gouvernement du vote du
Sénat en première lecture je tiens
simplement à rappeler que l'article 23
sur les finances des collectivités a été
supprimé grâce à la mobilisation de tous
les des sénateurs de tous les bords le
gouvernement et les députés s'y sont
ralliés en nouvelle lecture on peut pas
dire d'un côté que nous ne sommes pas
écoutés et que de l'autre côté nous
n'avons obtenu gain de cause car s'il y
a bien une priorité qui n'a pas varié
c'est la vôtre en dépit des changements
dans les prévisions macro-économiques
vous avez rétabli à l'identique la
trajectoire que vous avez voté en
première lecture et pour reprendre votre
formule sans prise en compte des
arguments du gouvernement et de nos
collègues députés j'ajoute enfin que nos
débats l'an dernier auraient pu nous
ouvrir les yeux sur la nécessité d'être
un peu plus cohérent dans nos votes vous
ne pouvez pas comme l' rappelé
indirectement Claude renal nous donner
des leçons de maîtrise budgéaire tout en
fixant des trajectoires que vous n'êtes
pas en mesure de respecter vous-même la
majorité sén ial l'a démontré l'an
dernier lors de la période budgétaire
suppression de recettes suppression de
33 milliards d'euros de crédit
budgétaire et le ministre Gabriel Attal
avait alors très justement souligné que
sans ce trompelœil qui vous a conduit à
supprimer l'ensemble des crédit de
l'agriculture ou de la cohésion des
territoires nous nous serions retrouvés
avec un déficit aggravé un déficit qui
ne respez pas la trajectoire que vous
aviez vous-même défendu en loi de
programmation des finances publiques et
cette année le projet doit de finance
nous offre un nouvel exemple de cette
incohérence au stade de la commission un
seul amendement du groupe les
républicain permet de véritablement de
réduire la dépense publique un seul sur
des centaines qui se chiffrent à près de
100 milliards d'euros je le dis souvent
en commission chez les républicains on
veut bien parler d'économie mais on est
nettement moins enthousiaste quand il
s'agit de dire lesquel et de les faire
soyons collectivement responsable pour
maîtriser nos trajectoires budgétaires
et ainsi transmettre des signaux
positifs aux institutions européennes en
respectant nos engagements céat cela
étant contenu de la dénaturation du
texte en commission qui selon nous crée
des difficultés et des incohérences le
groupe RDPI s'abstiendra
JECI merci Monsieur Rambo la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Stéphane sotarel
pour le groupe les républicain ceci pour
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers
collègues si la loi de programmation des
finances publiques constitue une
nécessité à plusieurs égards l'exercice
s'apparente de plus en plus à une
interminable contrainte formelle pour le
gouvernement qui doit rendre sa copie à
Bruxelles pour débloquer les fonds
européens du plan relance sans que vous
sembliez vraiment vous préoccuper de son
contenu pour le Parlement disposer d'une
LPFP constitue un moyen de contrôle de
l'exécutif dont on voit bien combien il
est nécessaire au regard des dérives
qu'ont connu nos finances publiques
depuis 7 ans mais aussi malheureusement
si peu suivi cette nouvelle copie malgré
quelques progrès reste peu satisfaisante
l'ambition et les efforts demeurent
limité le volontarisme insuffisant et
surtout vous semblez bien optimiste dans
vos hypothèses que ce soit au niveau de
la CRO croissance ou encore de la
contribution du commerce extérieur comme
du recul du taux d'épargne il faut en
outre noter que nos prélèvements
obligatoires resterit un niveau très
élevé à 44,4 % qui plus est sans que
l'efficacité de nos dépenses publiques
le justifie cela confirme qu'il faut
d'abord réduire la dépense avant
d'envisager de baisser cette pression
fiscale qu'on ne peut en aucun cas
imaginer alourdir en revanche nous
devrons impérieusement réformer la
fiscalité locale que l'État s'est
employé à détruire sans vision
territoriale depuis 2017 la France sera
le dernier élève de la classe Europe à
passer sous la barre des 3 % de déficit
public et encore sur le fil puisque cela
ne doit advevenir qu'en 2027 ce n'est
pas satisfaisant et nous vous proposons
d'accélérer ce redressement dès 2025
plus encore à cette échéance de 2025
notre dette publique restera fixé à plus
de 108 % du PIB cela n'est ni soutenable
ni acceptable au regard de la situation
de nos grands voisins européens en effet
d'une part dès 2024 la charge de la
dette va devenir le premier poste de
dépenses et d'autre part l'Allemagne est
déjà à moins de 70 % et la zone euro à
90 %. nous savons que le chemin sera
long mais nous proposons de ramener ce
ratio à 105 points l'État ne s'impose
guerre d'effort à l'air qui contraint
les collectivités dans la trajectoire de
la dépense publique cela va exiger des
efforts tout à fait considérables et
d'ailleurs fort peu documenté hors loi
de programmation sectorielle et que l'on
a du mal dans le projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 puisqueil se résume
seulement à 2 milliards d'euros
d'économie hors dépenses exceptionnelles
nous vous proposerons de modifier cette
trajectoire et de la rendre plus
exigeante la réduction de l'emploi
public en particulier n'est pas au
rendez-vous plus 8000 emplois dans le
PLF 2024 là aussi nous
réintroduirons la la la baisse pardon de
5 % que nous avions proposé en première
lecture j'en viens à l'effort demander
aux collectivités territoriales dans
votre projet de loi de programmation la
raison a prévalu avec le maintien de la
suppression de l'article 23 dont on ne
sait comment il avait pu être imaginé à
l'origine le solde des administrations
locales dans le solde global se
détériore mais surtout le montant
maximal des concours financiers de
l'État au collectivité territoriale
reste à un niveau qui ne semble pas
répondre aux enjeux d'un pays
décentralisé et au respect de l'histoire
l'effort de réduction de baisse de 0,5 %
par an des dépenses est bien différent
de ce qui est demandé à l'état et
surtout bien risqué quand on sait que ce
sont les collectivités qui assurent dans
notre pays la cohésion nationale nos
collectivités connaissent un effet de
ciseau que leurs efforts de gestion car
elles elles en font masquent encore dans
les ratios elles ne représentent que 8,4
% de la dett publi et ne sont en rien
responsables de notre déficit public
excessif et subissent avec notamment une
substantielle de leur charge un
tassement de leur autofinancement qui va
considérablement limiter
l'investissement public dans notre pays
c'est une faute de condamner le seul
moteur public qui fonctionne encore en
conséquence notre groupe comme il
l'avait déjà fait en 2022 en
responsabilité propose l'adoption du
texte modifié qui doit insuffler une
exigence nouvelle et tenue et offrir une
sage voie démocratique je vous
remercie merci monsieurarel laion
général les clauses nous pensons nous
passons désormais à la discussion du
texte de la commission et sur l'article
1er je suis saisi d'un amendement
amendement numéro 11 présenté par
Monsieur salvelli boet et les membres du
groupe CRCE kanaki monsieur Boquet oui
merci monsieur le Président oui
amendement qui propose la suppression de
l'article 1er un article qui